welcome to the beginner breakdown I'm
Mike cuckoo yeah and go to my go to my
Twitter feed let's see what is my
Twitter feed what is it at big comm stl
and read my last tweet which I don't
understand but if I was a real Mike
comer then I would understand it so I'm
going to take a page out of Mike's book
and try to insult as much as possible
players who were total beginners because
that seems like the fairest okay
and I looked in the mirror today and
what did it say it said I was the
fairest of them all so all right now if
you're going to make fun of somebody you
should start at the top right and who's
the top of the chess club the Chess Club
founder Rex Sinquefield now as Rex told
me a few weeks ago I'm the only
Grandmaster he's ever played in a rated
tournament rated game we played in 2011
so I'm going to do a little bit
different than my Kummer
a little different but I'll try to do
you know the same voice and you know
I'll try to lose 200 pounds during the
broadcast I look like them but anyway I
played Rex in 2011
Rex is rated between 16 and 17 hundred
and I had the black pieces now normally
Mike who's rated 1700 ish plays players
rated in the 200 range you know Anna and
I'm being nice so since that difference
in rating is is quite a bit I'll try to
show games where my opponents are in the
more the seven 800 range okay now Rex of
course is much better than that I was
black at a Carol con which starts efore
c6 d 4 D 5 okay I don't think Mike will
complain about that okay and Rex played
his favorite variation which is anybody
the boring variation now now grandmaster
is after they trade on d5 would play see
for the so called pandava Vanek attack
aimed after mr. attack okay but he
played Bishop d3 which is a little more
boring but it's not Bishop f5 now
there's two ways for blacks to play
after 96 which attacks the pawn on d4 c3
Knight f6 Bishop f4 Black has two things
he can do if he plays e6 which a lot of
beginners play to get their Bishop out
then this Bishop can't move so
grandmasters either play Bishop to g4
unless well that's the intoxicated
Grandmaster which would which is most of
us okay they play Bishop to g4 attacking
the Queen and then they play six and
that's the most common way of playing
but I don't want to play like a common
way because then my opponent will know
it so I always play g6 in this position
i fee and count on my bishop and if you
look at the pawn structure for white
White's pawns most of them are on dark
squares since white square bishop is
pretty good it's not blocked by pawns so
I'm going to trade off those bishops
okay now it's a good thing my comers not
here today
you push okay
it's a good thing my comers not here he
doesn't like doubled pawns okay now I
sort of agree with him when he's right
which isn't very often but he's been
right occasionally we called Mike Mike
the broken clock comer he's right he's
right twice a day okay so we we play
this okay now this position you play the
move Bishop to f5 trading off White's
good Bishop White's very happy to double
your pawns okay and so yep Mike would
probably say Black's losing here with
those double pawns but actually black
has very good control of the e4 square
okay I have pawns that control e4 and
the G file can be used by either player
maybe white will checkmate me maybe I'll
check made him I'm assuming if I got
checkmated you wouldn't know about this
game I think Rex would be up here
lecturing so we'll see what happens okay
Queen c2 now this is a typical mistake
that a lot of beginners would make now
Rex isn't a beginner but he took about
thirty five years off of playing chess
I don't know what he was doing I think
he was sleeping okay I don't think you
do anything I don't know then he woke up
but there was a chess club here I'm not
sure how that happened that's amazing
and lower rated players beginners those
of you in the audience you like to
attack things
the Queen is attacking the pawn Oh No
okay and I have two really obvious moves
and they both stop Queen takes pawn
one is e6 which I'm going to play anyway
and what is 94 which I'm also going to
play anyway
which one did I play this game was
played four years ago I don't know all
right
so 94 yay aggressive okay my Knights
really good on e4 95 we traded okay this
looks correct
I played f6 attacking his bishop and I'm
assuming he retreated it there we go
and then I play Queen to d7 Queen to d7
does something that you want to do in
chess that not a lot of players do that
connects your rooks Rex already did that
his rooks are connected so here I'd
probably rather have black for one
reason my Knights on e4 and he can't get
his Knight to e5 because I have e5
protected and I have a lot of pawns in
the center one of the good thing about
doubled pawns when they capture this way
is you have more pawns of the center
okay he played f3 kicking out my knight
I moved by night he attacked my knight
again that's the second mistake his
first mistake was putting his Queen on
the square attacking my pawn which was
easily defended now he attacks my knight
but his King is being exposed you want
all the pawns in front of your King and
now that he's played h4 well that was
the wrong button to push class dismissed
no okay now when I open the G file this
Bishop on g3 isn't protected anymore the
white pawn should really stay on h2 now
my comer might like age 4 and h4 would
be a good movie checkmates me but he
doesn't really have any pieces attacking
the main problem with White's position
here is this silly night okay that night
can go anywhere he'd like to play Knight
f3
maybe 94 maybe Knight c4 but you can't
make any of those moves so the Knights
sort of stuck on d2
so my Knights moving around and
hypnotizes him Knight f6 94 95 97 and
then when he falls asleep I can take
some of his pieces off the board
okay you guys never do that that's why
you're not grandmasters okay all right
so f4 frankly terrible okay that's the
third mistake so Rex was pretty
convinced correctly so but I was going
to play e5 then I would have a very nice
Center and I have a knight protecting e5
and a pawn on f6 and a bishop on g7 so
I'm going to play e5 eventually and he's
like no you're not he plays out four
okay so I won't play e5 but he's giving
away control of all the white squares
because all of his pawns are on dark
squares and he has a dark squared bishop
behind it if his dark square bishop was
in front of his pawns what I would
probably be illegal I was just take it
so his position is quite bad now my
Knights going to go to good squares I'm
going to tack on the G file and that's
what happened King H a getting ready for
the assault on the G line Rep Bishop h6
Knight d6 my Knights moving around a lot
rook c8 hitting his pawn to his queen
and my night went to e4 so I played 99f
694 Knight g5 97 Knight back to e4 okay
now we're back to square one okay that
with so many arrows there's no defense
this should be three ripped to g4 and
you can see my pieces are very active
and the most important feature of the
position earlier was his knight on g2
being bad now the most important
features his bishop on e3 it's behind
all of his pawns and that's not good as
bishop is an active night f1 the other
work to GA this looks like fun night h2
attacking my rook
yum-yum-yum that's the official term
Queen e2 Queen back to EA the Queen
wasn't really doing much on d7 but
defending this pawn but now the pawns
are not attacked I can go over to the
Kings side backward
kingside right now couldn't have said
that four years ago okay say four years
ago this might have actually been was
that bakery this place was what's that
parking lot oh yeah this is the parking
lot yeah that's what I meant yeah so we
were in the parking lot exactly that's
nice outside today okay so nine change
III and now you have to be at least 10
years old to see this because it gets
sort of violent do you have ID young man
okay that's good enough for me
what about you Juliana how old you are
if you were German I would say you're
dying nein nein but I think you're older
than that okay so queen f to man now
it's looking good for me you you oh you
like blacks position only only one Queen
darn okay 94 check that's a discovered
Shack because I discovered it he's in
Shack and his queen is attacked so now
he did what he should have done long ago
resigned that I could be the head of the
chest oh wait a minute just the chess
game okay so that was a fun game because
my opponent's Bishop never got any good
and his Knight didn't really do anything
either I like that I played 94
then I got my knight back to e4 and I
used all my pieces to attack and you may
have noticed you might not have that
this rook never moved
okay rook is on his rooks very
embarrassed that's why it's red I need a
smarter audience are you going to
smarter at home no you're not don't nod
your head come on
hold on I'm insulting the people at home
come on you guys you know come on you
don't even know who won this game right
the black one but that's right black one
not white okay so let's go to the next
game I push actually that destroys the
whole video yeah I know I'm kidding
okay so let's see now build Tom's that's
too boring so we skip that okay so this
game was against verge also not too much
of a beginner but he played like one so
he
he was hooking me up for my class okay
this was also in 2011 and I played my
favorite first move exactly okay I play
it occasionally what move did I plan
move one you that's because you know the
game B three very good okay and I get to
feeling ket on my bishop and I did pray
and I think this was the first rated
game that a virgin I played together
think so
Alex used to work at the Chess Club as
did everybody basically and now works at
a bank so there you go very suspicious
ninety-six III okay and I play Bishop b5
now sometimes in blitz chests but very
rarely in tournament chess I win
material here because I have a threat
the previous move I can't take the pawn
on e5 because his knight would take my
bishop so by playing Bishop b5 I want to
remove the defender and then take on e5
which I often do in blitz games okay but
you can't fool avert so early in the
morning this game was played at night
maybe I can fool okay he played d6
defending his pawn but pinning his own
Knight d4 attacking the pawn again he
takes and now I have four possible
captures let's vote you can vote for
Bishop takes Knight Bishop takes pawn
Queen takes or pawn takes now if you
want to vote at home go to my GoFundMe
page and the more money you pay the more
votes you get okay that makes sense
right the more you pay the more you
learn question what's one what's vote
mean you're too young the votes you
can't know all right but your mom can
vote for you okay yeah he's like all
right okay yeah all right who votes for
taking the pinned piece terrible who
votes for that okay who votes for pawn
SIG's blocking in my bishop what I'm
shaking my head okay
who votes for this other one I didn't
play this [ __ ] ain't now alright and I
played Queen takes array and then he
took my queen and I resigned no all
right
and it looks like somebody gave $800,000
and they suggested pawn takes so now I
played pond takes things changed okay
now he didn't take my queen due to its
illegality and if Robert Hess was here
nah doesn't work okay so he played
Bishop d7 threatening my queen naturally
this was a game played last year between
two super GM's
I think Nakamura Anand from like maybe a
blitz tournament or rapid tournament and
white one very quickly as quickly as me
but not come we're still learning okay
so Bishop takes and I think knock up
where we've just Queen here alright
Bishop takes Bishop takes raise your
hand what's black threatening we should
call somebody new somebody who's like
don't call on me don't call on me don't
call on me Julian
very good Emily's like okay so Bishop
takes g2 winning for black question okay
so did I allow Bishop takes g2 what
would the Germans say no they would say
it's don't think so okay those Germans
need to go back to school okay so I
played Knight f3 everybody's happy
he played Bishop e4 attacking my pawn if
you're a beginner out there and you are
I don't like Bishop e4 because he's
moved his Bishop several times okay he
played Bishop g7 Bishop c6 Bishop e4 and
his plan is to play Bishop c2 and I'm
like you want to win a pawn win upon and
I played nine c3 and I was fairly
certain he would take my pawn which he
should do and then I have compensation
because he's made thousand bishop moves
question well he might not play Bishop
c6 yeah answer that question yes
he should take it that's why he played
Bishop before but now he played c5
attacking my queen I didn't see it
because this is a beginner class so I
lost okay next game no wait a minute I
did see it Queen to d2 d5 and now I
castled
but which way did I Castle also I'm I
got a castle this game was played four
years ago I don't know yes that way hold
on I have to look now that's the Kings
side you're almost right that's true
actually I got a castles I don't know
I'm going out of Castle now all right I
Castle queenside this puts pressure here
so basically I stand in Kings side but I
Castle queenside so you are what you eat
wait a minute no you're not alright well
I didn't eat here so it's okay alright
my opponent played Bishop e7 ready to
castle and I played Knight g5 rawr why
did I do that
well I want to take this obviously and
the bishop is defending this pawn on d5
which I have a lot of attackers on so
that puts a lot of pressure on him why
did I put pressure on him thanks for
asking because I cancelled and I have
all my pieces out and he didn't Castle
and it's my move so instead of playing a
boring move like King to be one rook H
to e1 h 391 I played an aggressive move
which I rarely do Knight g5 he castled I
took and now he made the losing move why
is it good that he made the losing move
because he was playing me
very good somebody's been in my class
before okay now here he's already losing
because if he plays the correct to move
he'll lose a long endgame and he
shouldn't do that because my next
lectures on the endgame
this one's on beginner breakdown he
played Knight takes e4 losing all of his
pieces if he plays pawn takes Knight
then I take he takes back with something
that's something right ok then I get rid
of the defender and then I have a free
pawn and White's upon
up and with my great endgame technique I
would be lucky to hold the draw but yeah
pretty good a game technique okay so
instead of being down a pawn he decided
to lose more material okay that way it's
good for beginner breakdown
thanks for he played nine takes e4 okay
now White has a forced win winning the
game with a discovered attack beginners
class not 1992 class terrible your
ratings lower than the year you were
born come on man
come on what's wrong with you yeah
terrible alright so first of all what
trade did I make this should be my game
with racks because he's for fair trade
so yeah this was an unfair trade though
okay so what trade you unknown person me
and you're a magician 94 if you at home
don't think that's funny it is okay and
now he did something so shocking I can't
even show you so by now he played the
movie would all play Queen c7x clam now
you know why he doesn't come to the club
anymore yeah okay so obviously frankly
if he takes the obvious move now I have
a winning what's it called yeah double
attack yeah yeah discovered attack etc
who can raise their hand you can raise
your hand at home I'll see you okay it's
true to you you raised your hand pretty
confident over here yeah what should I
do
that guy's right queen c3 now right now
but no no don't thank him throw money
okay so my Queen and Bishop are
threatening checkmate which is good
because then you win and the discovered
attack I'm attacking his Queen now you
have to calculate one variation so I'll
let you guys take a breath because
that's a lot for you this ship f6
attacking my queen I take his queen he
takes my queen or maybe tries to right
now White has
one winning move White has three
captures but only one of them wins one
of them is equal and one loses so you
got you know some percentage I can't
understand somebody who's not rated over
1900 you wrote takes F fate and the
important part of that sentence was
check and then I take the bishop next
move and I have an extra bishop and
Verge realized that so he was like
that's no good okay so he played Queen
c7 and I noticed there was a pawn
attacking my knight so I took that pawn
seemed like a good idea yeah now I'm up
a knight in the pond which is pretty
good so he did what everybody would do
he gave up because that way I wouldn't
quickly
okay so that was verges first game
against the Grandmaster didn't go so
well yeah so basically he got his deep
on pinned and he lost pieces because
they weren't protected properly and I
had a checkmate threat gray all right
now we'll get to the real meat of the
lecture which is very strange because
I'm vegetarian very good okay now the
guy knows all except combination is safe
okay so here I played Julian and when
you think beginner you think Julian now
this game was played also years and
years ago and Julian was rated 672 he is
now rated 772 much better much better
okay before he was terrible alright I
was black I was playing a ladder game
now Julian has a good record against me
this is one of the few games I've won
something like that okay if you go to
MSA you'll see I might be lying okay
also the NSA knows I'm lying
alright so I'm black and a Sicilian and
as any chess player knows except the
ones from out of town like Danny what's
my favorite Sicilian Sicilian pizza
how's your tire
nice cool it had aired it before yeah
okay we have to start back the view of
the lecture because the student just
walked in okay so what were you want a
little and now I played just gray and my
opponent resigned everybody clapped
that's what you missed
yes what's why what's the zillion mean
that's the name of the opening and more
importantly its name of a pizza
what is this supermodel night at the
chess club what's going on around here
usually we just have Julian here yeah
yeah kiddie before the lecture because
look who I usually will be looking at
here you know he's got yeah all right so
we got Sicilian going on and Julian the
oficio know that he is got anchovies I
mean play Bishop c4 okay Bishop c4 is a
move played by beginning players because
they get their Bishop out but that's not
a good Square for the bishop when your
opponent's pawn is on e7 because when
their pawns on e5 that you can play all
kinds of crazy stuff well the pawns on
e7 and they play e6 then they're going
to attack your Bishop and you're going
to keep moving your Bishop until I take
it like this game yeah you made a lot of
bishop moves and you down to a lot of
doughnuts little chocolate donuts the
doughnuts of champions you know if you
like John Belushi that was funny okay so
he castled and we played some good chess
over here were the best or awesome okay
and I play d5 and he saw it he's really
good he moved his bishop and I fee and
cut up now you play d5 this is a
beautiful bishop okay it was a beautiful
bishop then he play d5 now it's less
beautiful also there's some pressure
here these pawns can capture each other
as Gregory Chi Don avoid say the lion
from Lexington main thing tension can
you transition in English very good
tension mint in okay in Soviet Russia
chess teaches you uh question uh that's
the reverse of what I said cuz he's
funny yeah
one who well here these funds can
capture each other and now after a five
nobody can capture anybody but my pawn
sitting on d5 sitting pretty and I'm
going to capture this pawn
I hope okay now you went into crazy mode
okay that was your favorite mode back
then now it's like your second favorite
mode yeah your first mode now is very
crazy mode right
you played Bishop a4 attacking my knight
he was like I didn't move that Bishop
enough I'm going to move it several more
times okay so I defended my knight then
you played very aggressive okay or is
Teddy KGB would say very aggressive
right he blade Knight d5 again actually
loses a piece well done okay now I can
just keep pushing my pawns okay like a
robot for some reason and I trap his
Bishop this ship on the side isn't good
and it took him several moves to get
there to the worst square okay so now I
just push my pawns and win his piece a
six and after he moves his Knight I can
play b5 and c4 and I'm a piece ahead
okay and c4 is good because it's
explosive I hope you said that at home
okay so I want a piece array for me and
then the rest was silly up appease i
think i checkmated you okay now if i was
playing this game today
now that i'm very old i would still be
playing it it would be years later I
would play rook da Rick d7 King age 7
King back to H a finally realizing King
G eights the right square for it and
three years later I would win but this
is when I was young and powerful and I
played
you want him the queen is fine
well I'm black I'm black
okay he did try to Queen his pawn let's
see if he was successful okay first I
forged his king and queen seems like a
good idea
he made the worst move no no wonder what
she was better no but what she wills
computer-like okay so obviously if King
h1 Knight takes Queen is good luck okay
he won his piece back but at what price
okay now I'm threatening checkmate and
checkmate
okay now he followed your advice no what
did you what that's your advice now but
what was your advice then d7 all right I
can't stop that pawn now I could play
queen g2 or queen h1 I don't remember
which one I played but I know me I'm
going to play the one with the least
amount of energy so queen g - ؈ h ones
like an extra square come on not doing
that
alright checkmate obviously colored
bishops draw agreed no no wait a minute
that's not right that's crazy talk so
that was one of my better games against
Julian the only one I won that day maybe
I don't want another one that day okay
speaking of Julian here's a game with
Julian now this game was played last
year when Julian was 722
I mean 720 for ever I mean 742 Evergreen
Terrace no way that's a Simpsons address
never mind okay so he played c4 which is
very good much better than e4 okay now
he played the English opening so I
played the English defense right raise
the roof what's the English defense
anyone question what Oh
what c4 is explosive we'll explain later
yeah it's an explosive c4 is an
explosive it's true I wouldn't lie to
you okay so I play the English defense
you so b6
he played Knight f3 and g3 trying to fee
and kind of opposite me like some mirror
I can't understand okay so I took
thinking Julian that very good he won't
take back but you surprised me
now actually I have something to say
about these beginners a lot of beginners
I've taught they won't take back and
there's two reasons one is they don't
see it that's the main reason they're
like what I can take back that's awesome
okay the other reason like oh no my
pawns are double mycommerce oh that was
bad okay well double pawns might be bad
but losing a knight is worse okay let's
say I can't make that joke moving on eat
akes f3
and now c5 preventing d4 or so I thought
naturally I had this position when I
went to the United Arab Emirates in
round one against somebody I don't know
some guy and we won yay and he played
Bishop g2 jewels play d4 if I remember
correctly yay okay and I took and he
took back I attacked his queen and he
actually moved it here because he didn't
see my pawn on b6 terrible nobody to do
that okay that was my dream he played
Queen a d1 setting up for the next game
I played g6 and now you'll notice black
has two pawns that started in the center
and white has less how many does white
have zero spawns in the center so I have
a better center pawns but he has two
bishops boy am I in trouble now I'm just
kidding okay so Knight h6 put it in H
one of the main ideas of this opening is
I control d4 okay and he can't play e3
because there's no pawn there and this
pawn can't move backwards so I really
control d4 if I play Knight f6
my knight can't go anywhere so Knight h6
and I'm on to d4 or so I hope and that's
what I did hooray for me and Knight a5
attacking the pawn and I could attack
the pawn again and again and again and
then Allison chain sued me and I lost
earng yeah I lost the lawsuit Alice in
Chains because I said again too many
times no nothing yeah Spencer I'll get
it okay all right what you've never
heard of Alice in Chains you can't get
that joke okay so Queenie two defending
his pawn rook c8 attacking it again and
there's no defense thank you thank you
nobody's throwing money how does he
defend his pawn ah if he plays b3 very
suspicious because I'll take this and I
have a fork okay which is good in the
diner
exactly okay so he didn't do that or
maybe you did know you weren't 600 yet
all right so you played Bishop h3
putting it in in H on defending your F
pawn okay and I played Knight d4 don't
tell him his Queens attacked look
nonchalant okay now look chillon they
didn't do nothing okay so he moved his
Queen as its attacked
Queen d3 and I played Knight takes e4
let's take a picture of the board
because the Knights are so lovely
anyone know oh he's got a camera okay
now I'm threatening Knight takes b2
which is very annoying should I make
that joke nay have managed many times
okay so he probably did something about
you pointed nothing about it right yeah
I knew it I needed to do nothing about
it okay you played Bishop to g5
counter-attack the mark of a weak player
very good thanks for helping me instruct
the class nine times out of ten when
somebody attacks something you should do
something about it right Joe however one
time out of ten you could counter-attack
and then you've got you know some good
action going on not here here all of my
pieces are attacking Knights of tagging
be two Knights attacking f3 bishops
looking good rooks looking good there's
too much attack so he can't
counter-attack Knight takes beats two
attacking his queen now the best move is
resigns very good but you made a worse
move
no no question mark double question one
yes yeah I agree with that but by the
way I'd like to point something out that
was not that that that was not a
question that was not a question no okay
so I had to tell you a funny story
because I like stories I have a friend
named Jana stiffens who worked for
Google then Netflix then Google okay
because that's how he rolls they could
give him raises and he has a PhD in math
and he was sitting in on a math class on
a sub math class that wasn't his while
he was supposed to sit there right
actually that's nothing that's needed it
was a hard class actually it was a
computer class so he's sitting there and
he's like falling asleep kid college
class kid says I have a question this
will not end we have to edit it this
will be okay Andy okay I have a question
and he's like yeah and he says this
doesn't work and my friends like that's
not a question he just went back to
sleep okay he read my book sleep like a
grandmaster okay I can always sleep like
a grandmaster I have the grand master
bedroom okay much better than the master
bedroom terrible all right so now you
made the worst move in chess history
it's in the Guinness Book of Records you
can look it up now I'll wait that was
the best part of the lecture all right
and you played Queen d2 now the new
ladies in the class are going to get
called on so I would recommend staring
at it a long time okay
I've been calling on Julian too much
that move is quite bad because black has
a winning fork which lady will ants will
raise your hand first the one on her
phone are the ones watching no no no yes
no back there yeah indeed and I did play
92 f3 and I would call that like a
family fork but it Forks too much III
never forked so many pieces now if I was
in a kids class and I said it Forks the
King Rican
Queen half the kids would be like and
the bishop and then the other and then
the other half of B and the pawn yeah
the third half they'd be all confused
they're like where are we
where's the third half okay well they're
in the fourth dimension you know they're
playing they're playing with strings
that's what they do
yeah very good yeah okay I would have
said 14 dimensions but you guys don't
look so all right and now he made the
best move
as Martin points out is not a move right
very good resigns
yeah man Queen B - that wasn't your best
move yeah Queen d2 the that's so good so
my knight on d4 by night on beats who
did a lot of damage now I don't know if
you answer to this question but it's
very important which one of my Knights
is my King night and which is my Queen
night hmm
I know which one of these bishops is
which I played the h6 f5 how did the
other day get there a 5c for b2 they
both made four moves solid consistent
yeah hi now this is my favorite game
ever and we have the guest of honor here
Mario take a bow right now my reading
was 2600 because I was good this game
and he was rated 930 plus tax with no
tax because we're we're 501c3 with no
tax okay so I was black and I played
Sicilian he played c4 not very explosive
here okay and I he played he 5 again you
don't want to move the same piece more
than once unless you're playing me so
kudos to Mario b5 now I attack the pawn
he defends it and I attack it again now
it's hard to defend not impossible but
hard he defended it d4
but now d4 isn't defended so sort of
like a domino effect and I don't know
how to play dominoes so here I resigned
I resigned because I don't know how to
play dominoes okay so I realized it was
chess and I took and Bishop a Queen to
e4
before we played okay 95 now let's see
who's the smartest in the audience if he
plays queen takes d4 what should I do
yes I haven't heard from you today so so
this Knight takes this night oh oh this
Knight takes this night oh you want to
do this that's a crazy move no that's
the best move yeah
then I take his queen okay so I win
yeah so so wait a minute did he do that
now not ridiculous
he played Knight takes e5 I took he took
and I took now I'm ahead two pawns there
right yeah okay so that's good good
start okay now when your head two pawns
you should push all your pawns so I
pushed all my funds seemed like a good
idea
am i doing a good job pushing all my
pawns okay yeah I keep pushing on my
pawns
now I've done something that was in
Guinness Book of World Records
Connect five it's a new game okay I got
all these pawns I'm going to push them
quoting John footwell paraphrasing John
Ford or woods okay
Bishop to d1 this should take be two
attacking the rook give them a little
check King e7 my pawns attacked no now
who can count to eight who can do it and
if you can't see that but nobody raised
their hand they're like what who can
count to voice iam voice IAM a team
divided each HTTP chair cm voice IAM did
Shawn what's with him pronouncing it
wrong terrible back to Russia you
eight in Russian okay I have eight pawns
I don't want to lose any of them so King
e7 otherwise when the game's over
I got to put him back on the board too
lazy for that yeah then I would resign
yeah but he played g4 now what are the
chances I have all eight pawns when the
game ends not much but I took it okay so
now I'm stuck more pawns
now White has four isolated pawns I have
no isolated pawns gray okay this should
be three everybody's had Oh see father
was a pawn no I still have them all okay
and now my pawns are pretty good Julian
was like I beat somebody worse you're
the worst
okay h5h for now if your name is
Meredith anyone one no not you then what
rule that you learned today could I do
after the move h4 what's that called on
Poisson but I didn't do it because then
he would take and I would have all you
my fun so I didn't do that but I could
take his pawn on Poisson if I wanted to
but I didn't do that
I played III I was just going to ask
check notice how his king is in check by
my bishop yeah but I can't I can't risk
that
okay King g3 check King H to Knight d2
forking everything so he played Bishop
e5 working my pieces whatever do to him
oh wait yeah this game okay here
King it King g1 not I didn't expect that
e to check/uncheck okay and now I played
a move the computer said was terrible
and then when I played it so that's the
best right back me up yeah I played
Bishop f3 computers like Bishop f3 why
you playing that and it's like wait a
minute that's forced to me
okay rugby to rook see it now I want to
play rook c1 checkmate even though it's
not checkmate
cuz you give my bishop d1 so I'm wrong
again
okay he blocked it with 9c2
now I can't play rook c1 checkmate
however he blocked his own rook
he played rook beets who for a reason
that when he blocked his rook I played
d2 minute now I'll give you guys a
second how many pawns does black have
all of them I mean if I was playing bug
house I'd have more but this is the most
I could have so checkmate
by using all of my pawns now in a
beginner breakdown class we have to say
how badly black played black didn't
castle and black left is rook on h8 so
I'm not even sure who won this game but
with my five extra pawns and extra rook
I was able to pull through somehow okay
if only my comer was here he would like
that attack that's one of the most
brutal attacks I had I didn't sacrifice
anything except my dignity all right
so until next week this is Mike Camus
with beginner breakdown yeah and go to
my Twitter feed I can't say it due to
FCC regulations see you next time